America's comeback starts right now
[Applause]
[Music]
I will ensure that Joe Biden does not
receive four more years our country
could not take that
and I say that not in laughter I say
that in tears our country could not take
four more years that it can only take so
much
in two years the Biden Administration
has destroyed the U.S economy just
destroyed it with Victory we will again
build the greatest economy ever
[Music]
foreign
comes at such a poor time the
Republicans are quite divided quite
frustrated and Trump essentially
entering the room trying to place of his
you know old show tunes the it seems off
thank you
when you're do when you're leading when
you're getting getting things done yeah
you take incoming fire that's just the
nature of it
we will make America great again thank
you very much God bless you